hey if you let's support the production
of more Maloof university video
tutorials then please visit the support
move section on move University calm
thanks and enjoy in the previous video
we talked about how we could elongate
palmitate to stearate
and to other long-chain fatty acids in
this video I want to talk about how we
can make unsaturated fatty acids via
desaturation so that's exactly what
desaturation is it's making UFAs or
unsaturated fatty acids so how can this
happen what we can do is we can take
palmitate and we could we can get a
double bond put into it right so let's
say we draw this here this is
palmitoleic palmitoleic and palmitoleic
is just palmitate with one degree of
unsaturation and specifically that
double bond is noted here Delta nine
which means that the double bond begins
at nine and goes to ten as you can see
here it is of course drawn as a system
on okay this is this process is called
desaturation right and this is
accomplished by an enzyme called fatty
acyl Co a desaturates okay there's a
little asterisk there and I'll get to
what that means just a moment okay just
just like we do this problem palmitate
to get palmitoleic we can also do it to
Siri to get this molecule which is only
eight same idea we actually get that
double bond put in between the nine to
ten to the the the sort of convention
the way it's drawn or written is the
same and it's the same idea right
desaturation done by fatty acyl Co a
desaturates okay so fatty acyl co-eds a
trace is the enzyme that does this an
important thing to note about fatty acyl
Co a desaturates sometimes just referred
to as disasterous it is a mixed function
oxidase and mixed flux mixed function
oxidases require three things molecular
oxygen
it also requires nadh and it also
requires cytochrome B 6
okay that's a b b 6 okay i'm not going
to talk too much about mixed function
oxidases and their mechanistic details
and things like that all I wanted to
mention was that this desaturates enzyme
is a mixed functional oxidase I might
make a video I'm expunction oxidases
later but you can see here that we're
basically oxidizing palmitate to
volatility and oxidizing stearate to
oleate okay now only eight can be Oda
excuse me okay in Palmetto v8 are
actually they both only have one degree
of unsaturation so they are
monounsaturated fatty acids or MUFAs
right so this is a movie this is a movie
as well all right what if we wanted to
get proof us which are polyunsaturated
fatty acids we could take only eight and
we could turn it into we could turn it
into this molecule which is called Leno
linoleic excuse me viñoly eight okay so
the difference here is that linoleic has
of course one more double bond has two
of them and it's written here as
eighteen to right to show that has two
degrees with hydration and they were
specifically starting at nine and twelve
so we got a double bond between nine and
ten and between twelve and thirteen and
of course there's sis as well okay and
now we've got more than one double bond
so this is a buffa polyunsaturated fatty
acid okay and you'll notice here that
linoleic as these two pink asterisks
next to it and the reason why is because
linoleic is what's called an essential
fatty acid an essential fatty acid at
least here we're talking about for
humans okay
an essential fatty acid cannot be
synthesized by that organism
okay so it must be obtained from the
diet of that organism so humid for
humans linoleic is an essential fatty
acid which means we must consume it in
our diets in order to get it and we and
we do need it for our body and I'll talk
about why is the moment okay
so places we can get this from or we can
get it from dark green veggies like
broccoli and spinach olive oil almonds
walnuts and there are other sources but
the point is that we get it basically
from from plants right from our from
from our diet and so this desaturation
step here I've drawn these green
asterisks just to indicate that they are
sort of this this step even though it's
done by a fatty acyl Kuwaiti saturates
this is only done in plants and bacteria
as well okay so to give us this this
poly unsaturated fatty acid okay
which of course in our case is essential
okay
all right let's slide things over a
little bit
okay now linoleic once we have linoleic
an get more pupas okay so we can have
two different D saturations basically in
different locations to give us these two
possible products I'll draw this or show
this one here which is alpha linolenic
over here and over here we'll have gamma
linolenic okay and they differ
essentially in where the the next double
bond is placed in that desaturation okay
so over here to the right is
desaturation we put so we first of all
we started with two double bonds right
in Llanelli no liate between nine and 10
and 12 and 13 over here in alpha little
na we still have the nine a 1012 right
but we added of the one at 15 so there's
no this is a double bond that we added
here put that in a different color so
we've added to put it in let's do do red
so we put this double bond here right
and this
this is different from what's going on
over here in Gamelin olan a right where
we have we still have the the double
bonds between nine and ten twelve and
thirteen but here we put a double bond
between six and seven so that's noted
here in the convention here again all
these are all system bonds the
difference between these two different
desaturation is that this one over here
to the right has these green asterisks
which means that it can only occur in
plants and plants bacteria whereas over
here humans can do this one okay so so
I'm going to put here again the
different color let's do pink light pink
so humans can do this
this desaturation but they cannot do
this one okay humans cannot do this
okay so what does that mean about alpha
little n8 this is an essential fatty
acid as well hence these two pink
asterisks here so these two D
saturations with these green asterisks
are making essential fatty acids these
things cannot happen in humans that
cannot happen in humans and why is that
there they are reactions that make
essential fatty acids and these are
essential again for humans essential
fatty acids so a question that might
come up is why is it that plants and
bacteria can make these essential fatty
acids for humans but humans can't make
them themselves
um it I mean the real answer I'm not
exactly sure of but you can imagine that
humans I mean we we can you know go we
can we can find shelter to stay warm we
can we can put on clothes we can make
fires we can we have heaters in our cars
and in our homes and so we can keep
ourselves warm and and sort of maintain
homeostasis but plants and bacteria that
can't exactly do that plants I mean once
they're planted in the ground they're
pretty much going to stay there right
but they need to be able to maintain
membrane fluidity right and in order to
maintain membrane fluidity they can
increase the amount of unsaturated fatty
acids that they have right so it makes
sense that they would have to be able to
make these unsaturated fatty acids to
increase the concentration of those in
their membranes to maintain membrane
fluidity okay whereas humans they can
just get that stuff by eating them so
now why am I even bringing this up at
all so let's let's scroll down a little
bit now we have gamma Lindell in a and
alpha little innate keep it up here like
this
so alpha lanolin 8 can basically go on
and give us give rise to other
polyunsaturated fatty acids and it is of
course a polyunsaturated fatty acid
itself all right so it's a poopa and so
is gamma linolenic
so I'm not going to concern myself with
this right side anymore let's think
about this left side and you'll see why
in just a moment so gamma linolenic can
give us this next fatty acid called I
cost a try you know eight okay it's kind
of a mouthful so this is a twenty carbon
fatty acid whereas gamma linolenic was
18 carbons this we have the same number
of degrees of unsaturation as three here
three here but we have two more carbons
in acaso and i cost the Torino eight
okay so that means here we didn't have a
desaturation reaction we instead had an
elongation reaction right and we'll also
notice that with this Delta notation
here here we had three double bonds and
here we have three double bonds with the
numbers changed why do the numbers
change okay well if you think about it
where were the two carbons actually
attached were they attached to to this
end over here to this end over here or
to this end over here if we look at the
molecules we should be able to tell that
they were actually added to this end
here these two carbons came from the
elongation reaction right the rest of
this molecule ooh look at it looks
identical if we start from from over
here we have 18 17 16 15 14 13
that's if we think about the numbering
let's number a little bit differently
here
think about numbering this as get omega
one two three four five six right and
then we have a double bond there
alternate another double bond alternate
double bond here's the same thing and I
cost a trainee no eight right we have an
Omega one two three four five six right
and then the ripest this side of the
molecule is the left side of the
molecule pretty much looks the same in
fact if we just take if we consider this
part here until the
left that's pretty much this part here
and to the left right so these two
carbons over here at this carboxyl end
came from the elongation reaction and I
mentioned this Omega stuff here one
thing I want to go back and mention
really briefly is that linoleic and
alpha linolenic our omega fatty acid
just like just in the way of these two
are this one here is an omega-6
everything but they'll make a numbering
1 2 3 4 5 6 where the double bond starts
to at 6 6 don't make a carbon right and
over here this is a 1 2 3 so there's an
omega-3 fatty acid so omega fatty acids
are often talked about when people talk
about health and they're important for a
bunch of things and whatnot so I just
wanted to mention that as a fact to to
consider or be aware of anyway back to
these reactions so we got this I costs
right away so that's why the numbering
change in this step right because if we
add these two carbons over here at this
end the carbonyl carbon has to be number
one right over here carbon this was
carbon number one but when we add two
carbons in the end we're basically
pushing all these other carbons back to
numbers right so the six becomes carbon
number eight 9 becomes 11 12 becomes 14
so the double bonds themselves didn't
actually move we just added carbons in
front over here so that's why the
numbering change in that step and put
the double bonds themselves in move now
I cost a try anyway can give rise to
this next fatty acid here which is a
rakha donate conventions are given here
same number of carbons one more degree
of unsaturation so there must have been
a desaturation occurring here and that
gave us a record on e so we've got in
all these proof O's right we got poof uh
poof we're here now um here we just
added
a double bond right here right that
Delta five that's where this came from
in that step and we have yet another
proof of that were that we're discussing
but where am I going with all this why
is it any of this is important right why
am I talking about it at all well racket
Donna can give rise it's actually a
precursor to molecules called the
eicosanoids the eicosanoids and these i
Casta noids are 20 carbon signaling
molecules that are actually pretty
important and I might make a video on
those guys specifically but not here
okay so um the reason why I mentioned
this entire pathway here is to bring up
the idea that I cost the noise important
signaling molecules come from fatty acid
synthesis specifically the desaturation
of fatty acids okay now one thing to
keep in mind is where all these
reactions actually occurring are they
happening again it's the the endoplasmic
reticulum specifically the smooth ER
again because this is all lipid
synthesis lipid synthesis occurs in the
endoplasmic reticulum
that's the organelle that it occurs in
another thing that I want to mention is
actually pretty important an important
note to make is that the enzymes that
accomplish these reactions they actually
they they don't they don't act on free
fatty acids in the way that I drew them
here I've drawn all these fatty acids
that's just free fatty acids just
chillin waiting to be acted on by these
by these enzymes these along elongation
enzymes you desaturates enzymes that's
not actually the case the fatty acids
that are being desaturated they they
actually must be on a phospholipid so
I've drawn them as free fatty acids just
for the sake of simplicity so that I
wouldn't really get too complicated and
too messy although it probably did will
get a little bit messy and complicated
hopefully it was easy enough to follow
with the color coding and whatnot but
what you can imagine is that let's just
say that we're considering this
saturation and step up here from from
only eight to linoleic rice we have
we have oleate here and we do saturated
give it to give the no v8 that wouldn't
actually this desaturate enzyme wouldn't
actually act on this free fatty acid to
give this free fatty acid oh oh that
actually look like is it would just be
on a phospholipids you can imagine it
looking like this so let's say we have
start off with a phospholipid over here
and this phospholipid this is
phosphatidyl ethanolamine with only
eight on the on carbon number two what
we can do is of course we can have a
desaturation reaction to give to go from
olie eight to a phospholipid with
Llanelli eight instead so the whole idea
is that the enzyme just has to act on a
fatty acyl group that is on a
phospholipid and not just free so I hope
that video was helpful informative and
thank you for watching thanks for
watching please don't forget to Like
comment subscribe and share the video
with anyone who you think might find it
helpful thanks and happy studies